they found the team fight and now they
have three drakes and are looking to
take control over this final game
the two-man baron is going on right now
edg have no idea yeah and uh donald kid
can throw down the ultimate from the
ziggs the barons still going down
this is the world finals and they're
sneaking with two people
fighting their time they don't know
where the opportunity is mako goes in
pops immediately like a volume canyon
going to follow soup laundry gets
exhausted and khan now trying to
continue this fight some low health bars
as the flash comes forward khan goes
golden
if an aphelios has an ocean soul it's
like you add a bloodthirster on steroids
to an already ridiculously powerful
damage dealer against a composition that
does not have that the viper is still
alive though flashes in showmaker down
to 200 he's a sitting duck and it's a
double kill for scout now he's flashing
forward picking up all of the summoner
spells and it is good night for ghost
and an ace for edg
before we get into the video i want to
remind you guys that every second counts
is brought to you by cisco powering the
future of esports now on paper edg was
supposed to go deep at worlds 2021 they
were the lpl's first seed but many were
surprised to see them in the grand
finals against the defending world
champions dam one part of that is
because in their previous five
appearances at worlds edg had never made
it past the quarter-finals but in game
one of the grand finals edg showed that
they were ready to get creative to beat
the expectations in the opening of the
day we were looking at wow this team is
so easy to predict all these graves yes
all these dropping picks all these rise
picks yes exactly they stick with those
venus and yet they also take
one page out of the t1 book bazillion
that they showed to further complement
what was already a strength of the team
by the end of game three though it
looked like that win was just a fluke
damon turned a corner and now everyone
was expecting them to repeat their 2020
win in four games did they really lose
one game to give fans false hope
it does seem like it oh it's coming true
honestly though don juan have been so
good this entire year last year as well
so dominant khan damon's top laner was
set to retire and he refused to be
denied a world championship in his last
career game so while edg made it further
than ever it seemed pretty clear that
damon was going to smash them but that
isn't what happened instead edg stormed
back to give viewers the best grand
final series in world's history and in
game 5 with everything on the line a
wild two-minute sequence determined
which team would hoist the summoner's
cup and which team would return home
with only regret with no crowd in
attendance damon pulled off an unlikely
play that would have been almost
impossible under normal circumstances a
barren sneak 27 minutes into game 5 of a
world's grand final wait wait the
two-man baron is going on right now edg
have no idea yeah and uh donald kid can
throw down the ultimate from the ziggs
the barons still going down
this is the world finals and they're
sneaking with two people just two
minutes during a close game five
determined world champions that
incredible baron sneak and then a
furious fight around dragon changed
history but how did we get to this point
the draft for game five was focused on
the jungle with both teams picking their
side lane champions before round two of
bands i actually like going for mid lane
figure and saving for jungle counter for
edg because if don juan go for the zin
pick then you can play the trundle into
it and use the pillar so it's really
effective against it because pillar
there's no escapes for zen and with a
low low cool down ability you can
oftentimes put him in really bad spots
where he has to burn ultimate or even a
summer spell and damon don't take the
bait they see it coming a mile away
they're not going to fall into it they
take the trundle themselves in the end
with five bands narrowing the jungle
selection jj played xin zhao into
canyon's trundle a pretty bad matchup so
targeting zj made sense zejj
outmaneuvered canyon in the early
minutes of game four and even in earlier
games where his impact was more
contained xi was an important part of
edg's overall game plan but i do think
that when we talk about jj gonna have to
look at him in the context of the whole
series i do think that he overall has
had a an incredible performance
throughout the series he's had a 90 kill
participation things happen when he is
here he is the cornerstone of what makes
edg action happen but because dan won
focused their bans on shutting zhaeje
down edg managed to pick up a trump card
a first pick of felios for viper and
they knew exactly what he was capable of
with that champion flandre about to turn
mega keep your eyes on him tn goes for
the 1v1 heroes entrance it's trying to
protect the jungler as well don't be on
the backline incomes flandering but the
stop punches come on through flight
drive with a huge narrow ultimate maybe
this is it but fbx still firing out
goes five feet dirty
what how does viper do it still despite
the change in drafting strategy for game
5 the mid game looked pretty similar to
the rest of the series the gold was
close and with no early lead to exploit
objective control became a big factor to
be honest i feel like that if you could
describe this series it would be a 2k
gold lead
that's that just goes to show how close
both these teams are edg have been ever
so slightly ahead and a lot of early
games in terms of the gold but dom would
have done a great job of keeping even
that was good news for edg although they
gave up the first dragon and two rift
heralds they were able to grab three
dragons for themselves before the 24
minute mark they found the team fight
and now they have three drakes and are
looking to take control over this final
game that left edg one dragon away from
ocean soul a powerful health
regeneration buff that had the potential
to seal away the game at the very least
it would mean a very difficult fight to
the finish for damon in the moments
before the dragon spawned edg and damon
clashed in the mid lane everything now
riding on the cannon since the supports
have traded their alts already and
barrel has to flash as well yeah he's
out of position
underneath this turret desperate for it
but doesn't quite calculate effectively
as beryl limped away from a fight that
should have killed him it seemed like
damon had to reset and get ready to
contest the ocean drake but instead khan
and canyon crept towards baron pitt as
edg pushed the mid tower with the rest
of damon posturing in the mid lane they
worked quietly to finish the job wait
wait wait the two-man baron is going on
right now edg have no idea yeah and uh
donald here can throw down the ultimate
from the ziggs the barons still going
down
this is the world finals and
just as nasha fell had he been there a
bit earlier it might have been possible
to contest it and without the roar of a
thousand strong crowd the kind that even
ear protection can't stop you from
feeling there was no hint that down one
was up to something sneaky faced with
this incredible play edg should have
been worried typically killing baron
with your entire team alive at 27
minutes means you get to take some
initiative you can push down some towers
or potentially inhibitors depending on
the state of the map and the enemy team
but damon didn't find themselves in a
typical situation that baron didn't even
guarantee them an advantage on the map
their lanes were already shoved in and
would take time to push out so instead
they had to fight for their lives in a
fateful confrontation around the dragon
pit as edg closed in on ocean soul
effectively all dam 1 did was prevent
edg from taking baron if they won the
upcoming fight at dragon
sure baron buff grants a minor damage
increase but damon's incredible play
wasn't going to win the game outright
meanwhile if damon allowed edg to get
ocean soul it was very likely that the
game would spiral out of control and so
they moved towards the impending ocean
drake hoping to win the fight that would
decide the entire tournament it's done
one kia they're still fighting their
time they've got to worry about the
opportunity as mako goes in pops
immediately like a volume canyon going
to follow soup laundry gets exhausted
and khan now trying to continue this
fight some low health bars as the flash
comes forward khan goes golden
viper is still alive though flashes in
show maker down to 200 he's a sitting
duck and it's a double kill for scout
now he's flashing forward picking up all
of the summoner spells and it is good
night for ghost and an ace for adg this
is the team fight that decided the world
championship so let's break it down
second by second after some early
posturing from khan edg was able to get
into position damon on the other hand
didn't have much vision in the area but
the korean team didn't have to make the
first move mako's rakhan dashed out of
the dark and into the group dam 1 front
line knocking up 3 and giving flandre an
opening to engage with kennen's slicing
maelstrom even though he was killed by
showmaker before his targets hit the
ground mako's sacrifice was not in vain
edg sensed their moment
and viper playing a felios put canyon
down now without their jungler and his
smite the best way for danwon to control
the dragon was simply to win the team
fight as beryl tried to escape viper
followed to confirm the kill while the
rest of edg stood their ground against
the remaining dam 1 players xi secured
the ocean drake and khan pounced on him
but viper finished off beryl that same
moment you know mako and jj going in to
die
but basically what they're doing is
they're going into soap cooldowns you
look at dumb ones team comp
it's all about playing around
10 seconds 12 seconds of certain
specific cooldowns that can really
dictate a team fight and every single
one of them that they get is extremely
valuable turning back into the fight
viper had one thing on his mind his
support gave him the engage they needed
his jungler killed the dragon before he
died now with kennen's burst already
expended it was on viper to win the
fight
if they lost here if they were all wiped
out three dam one members would have
baron buff and 90 seconds to use it
death timers were long and edg would
have a hard time defending against dam
one's siege
so with his alt down viper went all in
he flashed forward the viper is still
alive though flashes in showmaker down
to 200 he's a sitting duck and it's a
double kill for scout now he's flashing
forward picking up all of the summoner
spells and it is good night for ghost
and an ace for edg the fact that when
viper then goes in to kill everyone and
like flashes forward and makes the you
know the big the big man play that is
after so many of these buttons are on
cooldown and what it says to me is that
edg even in a game five of a world
championship are still communicating
extremely crisply it was an eerie
callback to the lpl summer finals where
viper's decision to flash forward helped
win the series viper wiped out damon
with a triple kill taking their baron
buff with them the game didn't end
instantly but now with ocean soul a
three and a half k gold lead and a big
edge in vision edg had what they needed
to win and then
viper and mako are kind of like rotating
between top and mid top and mid making
sure that this vision stays cleared out
and the moment darwin tried to enter
this is where they're at most danger
beautiful vision toggle by the observers
really conveys the sense of tread the
dread that dom what are feeling trying
to walk in here trying to look for an
opportunity to get back into this game
if an affiliate has an ocean soul
it's like you add a bloodthirster on
steroids to an already ridiculously
powerful damage dealer against a
composition that does not have that and
he's never going to be in range of
showmaker if he's playing well right and
i think that showmaker was the only one
that could actually one-shot him if he
lands as it lands a combo that's the
only thing he needs to worry about even
when they got poked down edg were able
to use the ocean souls healing to top
themselves off and so that's why ocean
soul is so powerful in this specific
context especially because while it's
not what it used to be it's still
exactly enough for what edg needed to
accomplish finally with the elder dragon
coming up dan juan threatened it hoping
to get the fight they wanted but edg
took down canyon and with his smite out
of the equation securing dragon was easy
from there edg took their victory lap
grabbing baron and shoving in before
resetting for a final team fight do they
have it in them
in order to close this one out right
here there is one turret between edg and
history right now is viper dashes
forward showmaker goes golden but it's
not going to keep him alive mako is
going to be the sacrificial left but
it's a double kill already for flanders
lightning rushing his way out of this
one and now the nexus is exposed
domwankia are limping and edg at the man
advantage the nexus will go down and
against all odds edg will be your 2021
world champions they've done it the
two-minute sequence that started with
the baron snake and ended with the ocean
drake could have resulted in two
different timelines in one a repeat down
one win sealed the narrative of a
resurgent career and a retiring legend
won a well-earned championship in the
other the excellence of the lpl now
shone through perennial world
disappointments edward gaming and their
long-hauling veterans mako and scout edg
made history at worlds 2021 they
exercised their demons by making it past
quarter-finals and they did it by
playing a record 15 games in the
knockout stage when they beat damon in
game 5 it wasn't a fluke it wasn't
because of some sneaky strategy or weird
draft it was because they played as a
team communicated well and when they saw
the chance to hand viper he's a felios
they did and he didn't miss
even though he probably thought that he
was never going to get this champion he
picks it up and he's like all right this
is the i'm going to win champion and
then he wins uh something about that
confidence and that ability to just
realize
i'm the one that's gonna have to win
this game and then doing it that is so
hard in a game five in the world final
of all games like it's just nuts man and
damn one the team that many felt were
unbeatable in the 5v5 was shown that the
worst fights are the ones that you
absolutely must take especially if you
can't really see the enemy team when the
fight begins a two-minute sequence in
game 5 gave the lpl the revenge they
sought for worlds 2020 it gave edg fans
something they dared not to hope for and
it meant that mako and scout were truly
and finally rewarded for their loyalty
to the org but something else it did was
remind us that when it comes to league
of legends the narrowest of margins can
mean everything that when two teams at
the top of their regions clash
every second counts
on the next episode of every second
counts presented by cisco we're going to
break down the most infamous moment from
the stockholm major and it's simple and
bit
times it to perfection
and simple sitting
[Applause]
it's the tragic shot that almost changed
cs go history check it out on january
26th
[Music]
you